today marks our state's first day of
early voting for the 2020 general
election
there are 1.2 million nevadans
registered to vote this year
at our last check this afternoon clark
county reported nearly 18
thousand voters have cast their ballots
so far
as kate houston reports many voters
started to line up before those polls
even opened
the las vegas athletic club in the
northwest is one of 48 early voting
sites and as you can see behind me
we have a line of voters here waiting
patiently to get inside
a long line of early voters wrapped
through the lvac parking lot off of
rainbow and lake mead
many brought chairs snacks and music as
they waited some tell me they started
lining up well before the polls opened
we put our chairs out we had coffee
and we sat and talked until they opened
up during the 14 days of early voting
registered voters can send in their mail
ballot drop it off at a voting site or
head inside one of these tents to vote
in person
the clark county election department
says this ballot is the longest ever
with 70 contests and five ballot
questions
it was a large ballot so what we did was
filled it out at home
so when we came here we wouldn't hold up
the lines and stuff to let other people
be able to vote
there were many events to kick off early
voting governor steve sisselak went to
the boulevard mall to drop off his mail
ballot with his family and address
voters
decide what you're going to do are you
going to drop it off you're going to
mail it in you're going to go to an
early voting site
make a plan with your family and go
together governor sissellack addressed
the long lines saying there's been a
great turnout
we know that there's going to be some
lines and that's a good thing for us we
ask you to be patient
and take the time to exercise your right
early voting will last through
october 30th kate houston 8 news now
the clark county elections department is
reminding voters that mass
and social distancing are required at
all polling places
there will be additional staff to
sanitize voting machines and other areas
after each use